we have a voicemail number that number
is 219 to david p
this is my new favorite caller
this is a delightful lady from texas
who is very politely correcting me on my
pronunciation of something
i can't think of a a more delightful
recent caller than this check it out
hi david i just wanted to let you know
by the way
the voice cracking on no is
even more delightful let's listen to it
one more time
hi david i just wanted to let you know
that here in texas we don't say uvalde
we say you valdi it reminds me of you
pal me you know it rhymes
you valdi
please correct
thank you i know you're not from texas
but
that's the way it's pronounced here
you valdy
thank you bye
this is the best caller now i'm going to
admit to you what's going on with my
pronunciation of that town in texas
as many of you know i'm from argentina
okay when i look at that word
u-v-a-l-d-e
to me it's in spanish and it's
that's the that's the that's the
pronunciation
anytime i just pronounce a word the way
it should be pronounced in spanish
like
people write in and they go david oh my
god you're doing that pretentious
pompous thing where
it's sort of like when someone will very
jarringly interrupt what they're saying
to say gonzalez instead of gonzalez
and it's jarring and it's pretentious
and his pompous don't do that and the
problem with me not just pronouncing it
the way it is which is
is i don't actually know which wrong
pronunciation should i use you valdez
you've aldi i they're all wrong guys
right i mean it's just what i need to
pick the right incorrect america
anglicized pronunciation
of what we all would know as
in the state of texas all right so i
apologize i throw myself at your mercy
but that is that's my new favorite
caller on the bonus show today the
uvalde police and the uvalde school
district
are no longer cooperating with the texas
investigation into the shooting last
week in uvalde we're going to talk about
what's going on building on the story at
the top of the podcast today the supreme
court has blocked a new texas social
media law from taking effect what's in
the law
and why is it being blocked we will tell
you
and lastly there are more and more
democrats opting to vote in republican
primaries
merely to vote against donald trump's
nominee we're going to talk about
whether this is a good idea a risky idea
etc all of those stories and more on two
days bonus show oh the bonus show where
you want to make money everybody else
that makes money to find themselves is
bad well easy alex i invite you not not
to buy any kind of weird supplements but
just to sign up at joinpakman.com become
a member you can use the coupon code big
voting 22 to save bigly
and uh we will see you on today's bonus
show or if you're not a member i will
see you back here tomorrow